[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Today, I'd like to
welcome Dr. Jessica Tracy.
She's a researcher and
professor of psychology
at the University of British
Columbia in Vancouver.
That's Vancouver, Canada,
not Vancouver, Washington.
And she's the leading expert
on the emotion of pride.
I personally found her book
absolutely fascinating.
I think it will
be relevant to us
here at Google and
to people everywhere.
Please give a warm
welcome to Jessica Tracy.
[APPLAUSE]
JESSICA TRACY: Thank you.
SPEAKER: So today, we're going
to have a moderated question
and answer.
I prepared some questions
for Dr. Tracy ahead of time
and let her know what they are.
So she's not going
to be surprised.
I'll ask the questions.
And then after the
questions, we'll
have an open audience question
and answer with the microphone
right here.
And we'll have a
book signing over
on the table in the far corner.
So why do we need
to words for pride?
And what words do you suggest?
And can you give examples of
people showing both kinds?
JESSICA TRACY: Yeah.
So what we found--
so pride, it's
an interesting emotion in many
ways I hope we'll talk about.
And one of the most
interesting things about it
is we often think it's
a bad thing, something
that we shouldn't experience.
Right?
It's sort of this
sinful emotion.
It's considered to be a deadly
sin in some religious views.
It's egotism.
It's arrogance.
And in fact, what we found is
that yes, that's part of pride.
But it's not all that pride is.
There actually are two
different forms of pride.
And we use the same word to
describe them in English.
We don't have two
different words.
Interestingly, in some
languages, that's not the case.
There are two different words
for these two different things.
But in English, they're not.
And so we need to
make a distinction
between the kind of pride that's
I would say the bad pride.
We call "hubristic pride."
And we used that
word, "hubristic,"
because that comes from the
Greek's word, "hubris," which
in the Greek understanding, it
was someone who thought that he
was more god-like than human.
The classic example
in Greek literature
is Icarus, whose
father built him wings.
And then he used them to fly
too close to the sun and died.
And that's a classic example
of hubristic pride, someone
who thinks they're so
great, and theoretically,
has a downfall as
a result of that.
And I think
psychologically speaking,
there are real negatives,
that hubristic pride.
People who feel this
hubristic pride,
this sense of superiority over
others, do have many problems.
And typically, those
problems result from the fact
that they think they're
better than others.
And they use others in order
to boost themselves up.
So often, they will put
others down in order
to feel good about themselves.
This causes them to
be not very likable.
And so people who have a lot
of hubris tend to be disliked.
They're antisocial.
They're often aggressive.
They're manipulative.
And they have real
relationship problems.
But then there's this
other kind of pride.
And this other kind
of pride, I'd say it's
the sense of
confidence that we take
from a hard-earned
accomplishment.
Right?
It's what we feel when
we're achieving, when we're
working hard, when
we're being creative,
when we're being innovative.
And it's what motivates
us to put in the hard work
to create great things,
to do great things.
And that kind of pride
is really a good thing.
And what I argue in
this book is that it's
the thing that
makes us want to do
all the amazing
things that we've
done as individuals
and as a species.
It's what makes us want
to achieve and be great.
The term that we've
come up for that pride
is "authentic pride."
And the reason that
we use that word
is because it makes
a nice distinction,
I think, between
with hubristic pride.
Authentic pride is based on
the authentic or genuine sense
of self.
And we feel it when we
make a realistic appraisal
of ourselves, when we
look at who we really are,
how we're doing,
what we're achieving,
think about what we
want, and see ourselves
in a realistic manner.
That's authentic pride.
Hubristic pride, in
contrast, is based
on a more grandiose and inflated
sense of self, so inauthentic.
So that's why we used
the term, "authentic"
because it's a nice
contrast and it points out
this key distinction.
SPEAKER: Thanks.
So what is the message of
your book in a nutshell?
JESSICA TRACY: So I would say
my book has three messages.
So I'm going to give you
three nutshells or three nuts,
however you may
want to think of it.
The first is that pride
is part of human nature.
And this, I think, is something
that maybe some people
would know already.
But other people, I
think, assume know.
We feel pride.
And we care a lot about pride
in the US and Western cultures
because we're an
individualistic society that's
all about self enhancement
and boosting ourselves up.
So pride makes sense.
But in cultures where
that's not so important,
collectivistic culture,
more egalitarian societies,
they probably don't have pride.
And that's not what we found.
In fact, what we found is
that it is a human universal.
We've looked at the
nonverbal display of pride.
And it seems to exist
everywhere we look.
We've done studies in
Burkina Faso, West Africa.
People there in small-scale
traditional societies
who've never been exposed to
American culture in any way,
they identify pride in the
same way that Americans do.
So things like that are
good evidence that it
is part of human nature.
So that's nutshell one.
Nutshell two is the reason
that it's part of human nature
is because we evolved
to experience pride
because it's
adaptive, which means
it serves an important
function in human lives.
It does something useful for us.
And what that is,
as I was mentioning,
it's what motivates
us to work hard.
Evolution made it so
that we care deeply
about our sense of self.
We care how we see ourselves
and how others see us.
This is incredibly
important to us.
Pride is what we feel
when we're basically
doing a good job of building
a sense of self that we like,
that is the kind of
identity we want to be.
And this is really adaptive
because the kind of identity
that we're seeking typically
is the kind of identity
that our society
wants us to seek.
So it's a way of making
sure, essentially,
that we do what we need to do
to make sure that we're staying
included within our groups, and
eventually, attaining status
in those groups,
that we're basically
becoming the kind of person
that others look up to.
And that's really adaptive.
And then the third nutshell
is what we were talking about
before, that pride is
not just one thing,
that there is this
authentic pride that
motivates creativity,
achievement, innovation.
But there's this other kind of
pride as well, hubristic pride.
And I think both prides
are part of human nature.
They both actually
help us get status.
People who feel hubristic
pride do get power over others.
But it's a different
kind of power.
It's not based on achievements
and accomplishments
and prestige.
It's based more on taking
control, using one's arrogance
and aggression to get
one's way, and basically,
attaining dominance.
So those are the three nuts,
I would say, of the book.
SPEAKER: OK.
So what was it like
in Burkina Faso?
And how did you get a trip
funded by a university research
budget?
It sounds expensive with
all that air travel.
You'd need translators
because these people wouldn't
speak English.
You have to bring computers
out into the fields.
And also tell us what
it is you discovered
about pride in that trip.
You alluded to a little bit.
But I'd like you to
go into more detail.
JESSICA TRACY:
Yeah, no, totally.
It was not all that
expensive it turns out.
Air flights, I think, was the
most expensive part of it,
getting all the way to Burkina
Faso, which is in West Africa.
But other than that,
as a developing nation,
it's a fairly inexpensive
place to visit.
You can get a really nice hotel,
the nicest they have there,
for quite cheap.
So that part wasn't bad.
And we were able to get a small
grant from UC-Davis, where
I was in grad
school, that funded
this trip for me and my advisor
and two other people who
came with us.
And yeah, we actually
didn't bring computers.
It's funny you say that.
Yeah, it was interesting.
This was back in 2003,
which was probably
the last time I traveled for
three weeks with no computer
at all.
But we thought it would
be too difficult to travel
in Africa with a computer.
So we had no computers.
We did the study with paper.
Imagine that.
And we brought photos in.
What we wanted to
figure out was we
had found in California that
there's this pride expression.
And basically what it looks
like is-- I think you probably
all know what it looks like.
But it's essentially
expansive chest,
pulling your shoulders back,
tilting your head up a bit,
smiling slightly.
And we'd found that
people in California
recognized this as pride.
If you asked them,
what emotion is this,
they would say
yeah, that's pride.
And almost everyone
would agree that's pride.
And that's meaningful
because it tells us there's
something objective
and behavioral and real
about this emotion, that it's
not just this idea that's
in our head.
There's something we can see.
But we wanted to go beyond that.
Maybe it's just something that
people in California know.
It's a gesture that college
students are familiar with.
We wanted to know,
is it actually
universal as a part
of human nature?
And Burkina Faso is a great way
to do that because Burkina Faso
is an extremely poor country.
At the time we
did this research,
it was actually the third
poorest nation in the world.
I think that's still
roughly the case.
And so as a result of the
poverty that exists there,
the people who live
there really have
no way of accessing information
from other cultures.
And that's true even of
the people in urban areas.
But we traveled to a
rural part of the country,
out in the Western countryside.
And we were able, with the
help of a collaborator-- this
was someone actually
who was a village chief,
or his family had been
the village chief.
And so because of that, he
was a government official.
And he'd spent some time
traveling in California.
And that's how we connected
with him, through people that he
met when he was in California.
But still, he lived in
Burkina Faso at the time
and had many ties
to this village
where his family had been
the chiefdom family basically
for many years.
And so he was able to
connect us with them.
So we went to the teeny village.
And the people there--
I mean, really, it
was an amazing experience.
We go to this village.
And it's as if we're going back
in time several hundred years.
I mean, there's nothing.
We got a ride in a bus.
And that was the
most modern thing
that I saw anytime
we were there.
Everyone who lived there
lived in these mud huts.
There's no electricity,
no plumbing.
There's just chickens
roaming around everywhere.
It was an amazing thing to
see, like the kind of thing
you'd see in
"National Geographic."
I think it's the kind
of thing anthropologists
see on a regular basis.
But as a psychologist
who does almost all
of my research in a lab in a
university with undergrads,
this isn't the kind of thing
I typically experience.
So it was incredible.
And we were able,
with his help, to find
a group of 40 people who
reported to us that they
couldn't read or write.
And I should say the national
language of Burkina Faso
is French.
But very few people in the
country actually speak French.
I forget what the proportion is.
But most people just
haven't gone to school
so haven't learned French.
So they speak a local dialect.
And all of our participants
were these kind
of people who'd
never been to school,
had never learned to
read or write in French,
and spoke only their
local dialect, which
didn't have a written form.
And so the nice thing about
that is these are people,
they don't have any access
to magazines or movies
or film from the West.
Right?
It's hard to think of how they
might have somehow been exposed
to an American pride expression,
or even a European pride
expression because they're
not seeing any kind of media
from these other cultures.
And that's really important
because that allows
us to say, OK, if these people
recognize pride expressions
in the same way
that Americans do,
it's not going to be
because they've seen
some American showing pride.
There's almost no tourist
industry there at all.
It's because this is
something all humans know.
Right?
That's really the only
reasonable explanation.
And that's exactly what we did.
We showed them photos.
We brought a binder
of laminated photos
of people posing pride
expressions as well
as other emotion expressions.
And we asked them
to identify them.
And sure enough, most
people in this sample
agreed that the pride
expression was, in fact, pride,
which to me is really compelling
evidence that there is
something universal about this.
SPEAKER: Cool.
So tell us about the Obama
speech about taking down
bin Laden, and the Trump
speech right before it
about birth certificates
and what they showed
and how that relates to pride.
JESSICA TRACY:
Yeah, so I used this
in the book as an example
of this distinction
between hubristic
and authentic pride
and the kinds of
leadership that each
promote because these are two
people who are both leaders.
At the time I wrote
the book, I should say,
Obama was president.
Trump was not a
presidential nominee at all.
I think when I actually
used that segment,
he wasn't even considering
running for president.
So I was more referring to
him as a leader in business.
It's interesting
how that's changed.
But yeah, so basically,
Obama made this speech,
which some of you
might remember,
when Osama bin Laden
was assassinated.
And it was really important
moment in his career.
It was his first
term of presidency.
He hadn't accomplished all
that much at that point.
So the reviews of him as a
president were not at all in.
This was his big
accomplishment to that date.
And so it was a really important
event for him to basically use
as a way of boosting his
status, as a way of promoting
himself and showing, look,
I'm doing important things
as president.
And that's something that
all leaders have to do.
And so the way that he
talked about it, I think,
is really interesting.
And if you go back
and watch the speech
or read a transcript
of it, what you'll see
is he talks about
specific things
that he did to make this happen.
He uses the word "I" a lot.
So he's referring to himself,
which is really important,
because he needs to get credit.
He needs to make it clear, I'm
the president who did this.
But he uses things like "did,"
words that express action.
Here's what we did.
Here are the specific
steps that I took.
And he really walks the
audience through those steps,
how the knowledge came
in, what he did next.
The other thing he
does is he makes
sure to talk about all
the other people who
are involved in this.
And there were a lot
of people, obviously--
the military, his advisors,
the American people.
And he gives credit
to all these people.
These are all
examples of what you
should do if you
want to convey pride
that's the authentic variety.
Taking credit, that's
an important thing
because feeling the
pride is important,
but talking about
specific behaviors.
So here's why I
deserve to feel good.
I'm not just telling you I'm
the best, I'm the greatest,
like some people do.
I'm actually telling
you, here are the things
I did to make this happen.
So it's based on
specific behaviors.
And crediting
others, that's really
important because
authentic pride
involves a sense of empathy
and care for others.
And it's really largely
about relationships.
When we feel authentic pride,
we feel good about ourselves.
But we also have a sense
that others are good too.
And we're able to acknowledge
others and their role
in helping us get what we want.
And that's really important.
It also helps convey a sense
of humility, which often goes
along with authentic pride.
So I thought that speech was
a great example of someone
who really, very tactically,
and I'm sure strategically,
use pride in a way to get a
status bump, which he did.
He really rose in
status after that event.
Now, the contrasting
example I give in the book--
and there are really many that
we could choose at this point.
But the example I
give is something
that happened right
around the same time
as the Osama bin Laden
assassination, which
is that Donald Trump
called a press conference.
Now, at this point,
he was just a citizen.
He wasn't a politician.
But he called a press
conference because he
wanted to announce something
that he was very proud of.
And he said, I am very
proud of myself for this.
And what it was that Obama
had released a long form birth
certificate, proving
once and for all--
we thought at the
time-- that he is,
in fact, an American citizen
and was born in the US.
And the way that Trump talked
about this accomplishment just
is a really stark contrast
to the way that Obama talked
about his accomplishment because
Obama actually never used
the word "proud," which
I think is important
because if you say,
I'm proud of myself,
it's a complicated thing to say.
It can wreak of hubristic pride.
It doesn't have to.
But I think we are
sensitive to that word.
Trump comes right out and
says, I'm very proud of myself
because this great thing I did.
Trump also says, I did something
that no one else could possibly
do.
So where Obama's crediting
lots of people and saying,
look, here are all the people
who allowed this to happen,
Trump is actually
crediting no one
and explicitly
saying, in fact, not
only did no one
help me with this,
no one else possibly could
have done this, which
is just extreme grandiosity.
So I think it's an example
of these two different kinds
of pride, which
end up playing out
in two different
styles of leadership
that the two individuals have.
SPEAKER: So you
talk about prestige
and how it goes with
authentic pride, and dominance
hubristic pride.
Tell us a little bit
about the difference
between prestige and dominance
as ways of influencing others.
JESSICA TRACY: Yeah,
that's a great segue
because that's
exactly the point I
was trying to make with the
Obama and Trump distinction.
Yeah, so we found that there are
two different kinds of status,
two different strategies
toward getting
status, which result in two
different kinds of status.
The first we call prestige.
And this is a status that's
based on accomplishments,
earned respect, and being nice.
So prestigious leaders are the
leaders who have done a lot.
They've done great things.
Others look up to
them and give them
power because they
know that doing so
will benefit the group,
both because these
are people who will achieve
things for the group
and because these are
skilled people who
have something to teach.
So the reason that we
follow prestigious leaders
is because we want
to learn from them.
They have something of value.
And they're either going
to directly teach it to us,
or they're going to let
us copy them in some way.
And so the interpersonal
aspect of this
is really important, that
prestigious leaders are nice.
They're agreeable.
They're willing to help others.
They want to help others learn.
Dominant leadership,
in contrast,
is not about being
competent or smart
or contributing something
of value to the group
or being respected.
It's about having
power over something.
Typically, dominant leaders
are people who wield control
over some resource.
And it might be wealth.
You can think of this in our
non-human primate ancestors
as strength, just I'm bigger
and stronger than you.
And they know they have
that power over others.
And they wield control over
it in an aggressive and
manipulative way.
And so what happens is they
force people to follow them.
They force followers to give
them the power they want.
And followers do, but
not because they want to,
not because they
like this individual.
Typically, they don't
like him or her.
But they feel they
have no choice.
So you can think of
the boss who threatens
to fire her employees every
time they question her mandates.
This is someone who gets power
not because employees look up
to her, but because
they literally
feel, I have no choice
but to give you power
because otherwise I'm
going to lose my job.
And there are lots of leaders
who use this strategy.
I think Steve Jobs is actually
an interesting example
of this, based on many reports.
He used to tell his employees
things like, if we fail,
it will be because of you.
That's a really
threatening thing
to say to someone
who's depending
on you for their livelihood.
And what it did, I'm sure,
was tell all of his employees,
I better do what this
guy says or else.
And that's how dominant works.
People follow them because
they feel that otherwise, there
will be serious punitive
consequences for them.
SPEAKER: So there's a
thing called a growth
mindset versus a fixed mindset.
Carol S Dweck talks about
it in her book "Mindset,
the New Psychology of Success."
In the growth
mindset, you worked
hard, might be what
you tell your kid.
The people try to grow and
are focused on getting better.
With a fixed mindset,
you might tell your kid,
you are so smart.
People value themselves
as intrinsically smart.
It seems very similar, to
me, to your descriptions
of authentic and
hubristic pride.
What do you think?
JESSICA TRACY: Yeah, I think
there's a lot of overlap there.
I think that, as you pointed
out, authentic pride,
it really is linked
to the growth mindset
because we feel authentic
pride when we think about what
we can do to become better.
Often, we choose to
do things because we
think it will make us
feel authentic pride
and because we're
actually feeling
that we lack authentic pride.
So we want to grow.
We actually have a study we did
that I think demonstrates this
nicely where we looked
at undergrads performance
on an exam, a real class exam.
And we asked them
to tell us how they
felt about their performance.
And we wanted to see whether
the people who felt pride
in their performance would
go on and perform better
on the next exam
because we thought,
oh, pride's going
to be motivating.
They're going to do really well.
And then they're going to want
to do well again in the future.
That's not exactly
what we found.
The people who did well did
feel a lot of authentic pride.
And they ended up doing
well again on the next exam.
But their authentic pride wasn't
really what made them do well.
These were the high
achievers, people
who work hard all the time.
So authentic pride
isn't all that
relevant to changing
their behavior.
And they don't need to
change their behavior.
But what was really
interesting is
that some of the people who
did poorly on that exam, they
actually told us that they
felt a lack of authentic pride.
They were missing
feeling authentic pride.
And that lack of
authentic pride,
we found when we asked
them a few weeks later,
that made them want to say,
I'm going to study differently
for the next exam.
I'm going to put in
more hours next time.
And when we looked
at their performance
on the next exam, those
people-- the ones who did badly
on the first exam
and then said, I'm
missing authentic
pride-- they were
the ones who ended up doing
better on that subsequent exam.
And we can trace their
improved performance directly
to that lack of authentic pride.
So this is nice evidence that
a desire for authentic pride
is actually what motivates
us to put in the hard work
that we need to put in
in order to do better,
to perform at a higher level.
And that, I think,
is a growth mindset.
And yeah, I think as you
pointed out, the other kind
of mindset-- I forget.
SPEAKER: A fixed mindset?
JESSICA TRACY: A fixed mindset.
Yeah, she often talks
about entity theories
and fixed mindset and
performance goals.
And all these things are linked
to hubristic pride, where
instead of focusing on
what can I do to achieve,
what next work do I need to do
to become the kind of person
that I want to be, it's
much more of a focus
on I'm just great.
How can I stay great?
And often, then, you
avoid challenging yourself
because you can
think about this.
If you feel great about
yourself and you're
worried about I don't
want to risk not feeling
great about myself,
that's kind of scary,
the last thing you want to do
is try to put in hard work again
to achieve again.
Right?
You are instead
focused on how can I
enhance these great feelings
that I have about myself right
now.
And that's counterproductive.
SPEAKER: So what is
cumulative cultural evolution?
And why is it important?
How does pride fit in with it?
JESSICA TRACY: Yeah, so this is
a really complicated question.
And I'll just say, this is
the topic of an entire chapter
in the book.
So I'll give a brief overview.
But if you're actually curious
about this, read Chapter 6.
That's my advice.
But basically, cumulative
cultural evolution
is the process whereby all of a
culture's creations-- and that
includes things like
belief systems, values,
religious ideologies, art,
science, math, everything
we create, technology--
all of that
builds upon itself over
time and progresses.
And the result is everything
that we use pretty much
in our day-to-day lives now.
And this is true for us and
people in every culture,
in human societies.
All those things are
things that could never
have been created by
one individual alone,
or even one community of
people alone because what
we have is the benefit
of communities of people,
societies of people,
creating ideas, and then
the smart ideas, the
ones that are useful,
sticking around, getting passed
on to the next generation,
and then in that generation,
one person, maybe,
innovating, finding a way
to do that even better.
And the best ideas,
the best innovations,
are the ones that then spread
throughout that community
and get passed on.
So what you end up
with is a community
where now, we have things
like Google watches and phones
that thousands of years ago
could never have existed.
And if you came along
today and started
from where we were
thousands of years ago,
you couldn't come up
with something like that.
But everything's building
upon itself, essentially.
In terms of where pride
comes into this-- basically,
cumulative cultural evolution,
which explains much of the way
that humans are and
other animals aren't.
It's really the best
explanation for why
we're different from
other species, I think.
And it requires several
different psychological
adaptations, each
of which, I think,
is partly dependent on pride.
So one thing it requires
is a desire to innovate.
Right?
You have to learn
something well.
But then you have to say, I'm
going to make it even better.
You can think of this in
small-scale traditional
societies.
The knowledge of how to
build a very basic level
canoe, that gets passed on.
But then someone
thinks, hey, I want
to make this canoe even better.
And this is a terrible
example for me
to give because I don't know
how to make a canoe better.
But someone did in
that culture, right?
I'm going to make it out a
fiberglass instead of wood,
or whatever it is.
And that is really
important because that's
the advance that then
gets the cultural concept
to the next step.
But in order to desire
to make that advance,
you need to have a motivation.
You need to feel
like, I'm going to do
things that make a difference.
Right?
I'm going to do
something that isn't just
accepting what I
have, what we have,
but actually taking
it to the next level.
And that's something that humans
do that really no other animal
does, that when things
are good enough--
when we're surviving,
when we're getting
by, that old canoe works
perfectly well-- we don't just
say, hey, I'm fine.
I'm surviving and reproducing.
That's really all I need.
We want more.
And that's because we want
to feel good about ourselves.
And that's pride.
So that's step one.
Step two is teaching
others what you
know because cumulative
cultural evolution depends
on social learning.
We have to spread the
knowledge that we know.
And that means
being prestigious.
Like I said,
prestigious leaders are
the ones who are willing to
teach others what they know.
They're also the ones who
tend to know the best stuff.
So these are exactly
the people that we
would want to be spreading our
highest knowledge, basically,
throughout a society.
And that prestige is attained
through authentic pride
because that's what
makes people prestigious
and makes them want to share
what they know with others.
And the last piece
of it is learning.
In order to really master
a skill, to master or learn
a piece of knowledge,
you have to figure out
who to learn from.
You can't just copy
or learn from people
indiscriminately
because if so, you'll
get some bad information as
well as good information.
And so what you need
to do is figure out who
the prestigious leaders are.
And it turns out pride is
really relevant to this
because people who
feel prestigious
and who are prestigious
show the pride expression.
We've actually found that when
people are seeking knowledge,
when they need to
learn something,
they will choose to do that
from someone who shows pride
more than from someone who shows
any other emotion expression.
If given the choice, they'll
copy the knowledge displayed
by someone who's expressing
pride, suggesting that pride,
basically, is a signal
of someone's prestige
and expertise.
SPEAKER: So what does this
pride expression look like?
Could you show us?
You've described it.
But I'd like to actually see it.
JESSICA TRACY: I know.
I know.
This is why I was saying
I should bring slides.
But we decided not to.
Yeah, I mean, I can
do a little version.
You tilt back your shoulders.
You push your chest out.
You can stand in a
posture like this,
tilt your head up a little bit.
Sometimes, you raise your
arms above your head.
That's the excited,
woo-hoo pride.
But that's not necessary.
We do find typically
that arms are
expanded from the body
in one way or another,
extended from the body.
There is this general
expansiveness.
That's the key part.
But the most
important components
are expansive chest, posture,
and head tilt upward.
Those are the key aspects of it.
SPEAKER: So what does
religion tell us about pride?
And what does Aristotle
tell us about pride?
And do you agree with
their approaches?
JESSICA TRACY: Yeah,
so various religions
have talked about pride for
millennia at this point.
And typically, the view
is that pride is bad.
This is the sinful
view of pride.
And lots of different-- mostly
Judeo-Christian, but even
Buddhism talks about
pride as something
that prevents us from
reaching nirvana.
So lots of religions have
really problemetized pride.
I think that's because
what they're talking about
is hubristic pride.
They're talking about the
kind of pride that makes
us arrogant and egotistical.
And in religions, the
goal is to teach people
that someone or something--
God or the religious leader--
is greater than them.
So if you're feeling
hubristic pride
and you think you're
the greatest around,
that's going to
be a real problem
for religious ideologies.
Interestingly, there are hints
of a more nuanced view of pride
if you look far back in history.
And Aristotle is actually
a good example of that.
He's one of the
few early thinkers
who said, well, wait a minute.
Pride doesn't have to be bad.
And he said, actually, you know
what's bad is if you're great
and you pretend you're
not, that's not good.
That's sort of lying.
That's deception.
In fact, a great
man is someone who
knows he's great
and acknowledges it
and is able to say yeah,
I have these skills.
And to me, that's
authentic pride,
that this realistic appraisal
of your own greatness
and a willingness to
acknowledge it, that can be OK.
And so that, I
think, is picking up
on this distinction between
authentic and hubristic pride.
SPEAKER: So here
at Google, we have
something called
Googliness, which
is basically being the kind of
people you want for a coworker.
It's really important
for our company culture.
But how does pride fit in with
being humble, not boasting,
and helping your
coworkers to be better?
JESSICA TRACY: Yeah, no, I
think this is a big issue.
Right?
And I think often the solution
that people come up with
is, I'm not going to show pride.
I'm not going to feel any pride.
If I do something great, I'm
not going to talk about it.
And I think it's very, very
tricky because authentic pride
is a good thing.
I think it's the reason that all
of us want to do great things.
Right?
If you want to develop something
new or create something new,
it's because you want to
feel good about yourself
at some level.
Once you get into it,
once you get working,
you might just
get in the mindset
where you're in the zone
and you're doing your thing
and you're not thinking
about yourself.
But what I would argue is
the reason you originally
decided to take this job, to
become the kind of person who
has the opportunity
to get in that zone,
is because of a
desire to feel pride.
At the same time, you
don't want to be a jerk.
You don't want to be that
arrogant person that everyone
is avoiding at lunch.
And that's hubristic pride.
So it really is this
balance between going
for authentic pride,
acknowledging it, wanting
to feel that, and avoiding
hubris, avoiding bragging,
trying not to talk
about your successes
to people who haven't
had so many successes.
You don't want to
be that person.
I mean, that's
one obvious thing.
But it really depends on the
social norms of the group.
And they vary dramatically
from group to group.
You guys probably know
far better than me
what the norms are
here at Google.
But they really do vary
from culture to culture
because clearly, there's
a culture in which Donald
Trump is doing
amazingly well, where
it's perfectly acceptable
and even valued
to go around telling everyone
that you're the greatest,
you're the smartest, you're
the best in all these ways.
I think most of
us in the culture
that I live in,
certainly in Canada, feel
like that's not really OK.
Even if you think
it's true, that's
not something you should say.
And there are cultures that are
even more extreme in that way.
If you go to Kalahari
Bushmen, which
is a really
egalitarianism society,
it's not OK to talk
about any success, ever.
And anthropologists tell stories
about people in that culture
where if they have
a success-- say,
they have a big kill in the
hunt-- when they come back,
the last thing they
do is bring it up.
He talked about this one hunter
who had a success and went
and sat by himself and waited
until someone approached him.
And then finally, when someone
approached him and said,
how did you do today?
He said, oh, you know,
nothing much happened.
It wasn't really a big day.
And that's what actually
tells his friend,
oh, something good happened.
Right?
Because he's following
this intricate set of norms
about how we talk
about our success,
while retaining this egalitarian
structure of the society.
And in fact, what people
told the anthropologist who
reported this is, we have to
require people to do this.
If we let them talk about
their success in any way,
if we let them show pride,
they would get too big.
And that would be
a real problem.
And what he told the
anthropologist is,
eventually, their
pride would kill them.
So this is a way of
protecting everyone.
So it really is about different
norms in different cultures,
about when it's OK and how it's
OK to talk about our pride.
SPEAKER: So how
do programmers who
are trained to be humble
authentically get prestige?
We're trying to care about doing
the right thing more so that
about raising our own status.
JESSICA TRACY: Yeah,
and I think that's OK.
And in fact, I think
that's a great thing.
I think thinking about
doing the right thing,
whether that's building a
new product that's great,
or caring about your
coworkers, those
are things that you
can take pride in.
And what I would say
is, it's actually
good to think
about those things.
What kind of Googler, what
kind of worker do I want to be?
What kind of person
do I want to be?
And then think about
what you need to do that.
Don't think about, how
do I get high status,
because what we found is that
the ultimate evolutionary
function of pride is
to get you status.
But that's not the
proximal function.
And so we make this
distinction between
the psychological
motivations that
are happening in our head,
the proximal functions,
and ultimate functions.
Ultimate functions are why we,
as a species, do these things.
And they're the
ultimate benefits.
But the idea is, if we do these
things for proximal reasons
like I want to feel
good about myself,
that's enough of a
proximal reason to do it.
That gets you to
do the behaviors.
The ultimate outcome is you're
going to get high status.
But you don't have
to worry about that.
Evolution has made
it so that that
will be the outcome of you
just doing the stuff that you
want to do because you want
to feel good about yourself.
SPEAKER: So a long time
ago, I read a comic strip
called Bloom County."
And as I remember-- I'm not
sure my memory is completely
valid on this-- they
started criticizing a number
of different political figures.
And there was one political
figure that they criticized who
then bought King Features
Syndicate that "Bloom County"
was a part of, and
cancelled the strip.
Are you afraid that same
political figure, a person who
is now a political figure,
might do that to your book
because your book
talks about him.
JESSICA TRACY: I'm not
particularly scared of Trump.
But I think many
people are, I will say.
I think that he uses tactics
of fear and intimidation
really effectively, which
is what dominant leaders do.
That's how they get power.
What I noticed watching
the primary season
was that that is a
large part of how
he won the primary election
is he essentially intimidated
anyone on the Republican side
who wanted to raise questions
against him.
He did this in various ways.
He used Twitter campaigns
to hurt people's reputations
if they were going to
say bad things about him.
He insulted his opponents
in the various debates.
And so all this had the effect
of making people afraid of him,
largely, I would
say, because they
were afraid of what he was
doing to their reputation
among Republican voters.
So if you care
about his followers
and what they think
of you, you're
not going to mess with
him because he really
has that power.
And so that's a
very strategic move.
For people who don't care
what his followers think
of them, which I think is
where Hillary Clinton stands,
you don't have to
be afraid of him
because what power
does he have, really,
over people other than the
people who really care for him?
SPEAKER: All right, thanks.
We're going to open it up
for audience questions now.
So the mic is right over here.
Feel free to come on up
and ask your questions.
AUDIENCE: What is the difference
between self-confidence
and pride?
And is there anything that
you talked about pride today
that doesn't really
apply to self-confidence?
JESSICA TRACY: That's
a great question.
So I would say that
they're very similar.
Authentic pride, I
would say, is very much
a sense of self-confidence.
Typically, we think
of self-confidence
more as a disposition, so a
trait that some people have
and some people don't,
or some people have
a lot and some
people have less of.
And authentic
pride, we can think
of more as a momentary
state for the most
part, although we
can be dispositional
authentically proud.
If your dispositionally
authentically proud,
I would say that's much the
same as having a strong sense
of self-confidence.
But what I think is
important is the way
that we use these terms.
Sometimes, when we talk
about self-confidence,
we don't distinguish
between what
I would call the
authentic pride and more
narcissistic confidence.
So some people who
are self-confident
are also narcissistic.
Or maybe that's
largely what they are.
They're confident, but in a way
that's grandiose and arrogant.
And I think that's a really
important distinction to make.
So I like using the
term "self-confident,"
but I want to be clear about
saying, well, self-confidence,
to me, is confidence in your
hard work and achievements
and productivity.
It's authentic pride.
It's not this grandiose
sense of self.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: You talked
about Eastern cultures,
which was one of the reasons
I actually showed up here.
I had an email that
landed-- I don't know.
This is happenstance.
It just landed in my
inbox today that says--
and I'll just read this to you.
And this is from about 2300 BC.
This is from the
Vedas, which goes,
"Education yields humility.
Humility yields character.
Character yields wealth.
Wealth supports
a righteous life.
And righteousness
yields happiness."
And so a central part of
most Eastern cultures,
at least the culture
that I come from,
is the sublimation of ego.
And actually, doing great
work is meditation in itself.
So when I sat and listened
to most of your lecture,
it really didn't
apply to me because I
am on a path trying to
actually sublimate my ego
and get rid of any of
the pride, whether it
be the good or the bad pride.
And so do you think I have no
chance in a Western culture
to survive?
JESSICA TRACY: No.
I think this is a
really important issue.
And my thinking is
that view, which
I'm familiar with the
Eastern view, as you say,
sublimate the ego-- as
I said, Buddhism really
is a big Eastern philosophy
and religious view,
depending on how
you see it, that's
all about avoiding pride.
I think they're
missing something.
And far be it for
me-- this is thousands
of years of knowledge.
But I think that really,
what they want people to do
is feel a sense of pride.
Maybe they don't
want to call it pride
because you think of pride and
you think of hubristic side.
And clearly, that's problematic.
And that's not going to do all
the things that you just said.
But authentic pride
is just the desire
to feel good about yourself.
And so my view is, you're
becoming this kind of person.
You're focusing on
sublimating your ego
and working hard and
focusing on humility
and doing all the things
you said, being righteous.
The reason you're doing
that is because you want
to feel good about yourself.
You have this sense of
self, this identity,
that you're building up.
And for you, one part of
it that's really important
is sublimating the ego, not
being arrogant, being humble.
But what I would
say is the desire
to do that, the desire
to build an identity that
meets certain requirements that
you've decided, that's pride.
Pride is what makes you want
to feel good about yourself.
It's not a bad thing.
It's not bad pride.
It's not arrogance.
It is just authentic pride.
And as humans, we evolved
to have the sense of self
that we care deeply about.
And there's an enormous
adaptive advantages
that we get from that,
from having a sense of self
and caring about our reputation
and how we see ourselves
and how others see us.
And so pride is the emotion
that tells us when we're
en route to achieving that.
And I think it's a good thing.
I think wanting to feel
pride in our sense of self
is OK, as long as we
understand that we're not
talking about arrogance.
We're not talking about egotism.
We're not talking about
putting others down,
and that a big part of
what we can feel pride in
is all the things that you
say-- being humble, caring
about others, putting others'
welfare before our own.
Being the kind of
person who does that
is very much something to feel
a sense of authentic pride in.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm coming to the
same thing like he said.
In our culture, I've seen
taking pride and saying that you
made this person proud.
You made your parents proud.
You made your country proud.
And getting the pride from that
happiness, rather than saying,
I mean, I did good for myself.
I'm happy because my
parents are proud.
JESSICA TRACY: Yeah,
no, absolutely.
So I think that's a great
point that we can feel pride
in our individual self.
And I think in individualistic
cultures, that's
a lot of what we feel pride in.
But in more
collectivistic cultures,
we are very focused on
our larger sense of self.
And we all have this.
Even in individualistic
cultures, ourself,
for every one of us,
it's not just me.
Right?
There's the self that you
have if you have a child.
There's the self in
that relationship,
or in your partner,
or in your family,
or your larger community.
You all probably feel proud as
someone who works for Google.
And you feel proud
of the company.
When the company
does a good thing,
even if you weren't
directly responsible for it,
you're going to feel a sense
of collective pride in that.
And I think that's great.
I think that's a
really useful thing.
It makes us care about
those who are close to us.
It makes us care
about our communities.
It makes us work hard
for our larger groups.
And yeah, I do think it's a
way of dealing with this issue.
And I think in collectivist
cultures, one of the goals
is to tamp down the individual
and make people focus more
on the collective self rather
than the individual self.
And that's how the
society functions
is that my sense
of self that's me
as a member of
this group, that's
the most important sense
of self that I have,
if I'm in a
collectivistic culture,
whereas in individualistic
cultures, my sense of self
is much more me
as an individual.
Yes, I'm part of the group, but
that's a less central focus.
This is a broad
generalization, of course.
There's massive
individual differences
within both kinds of cultures.
But I think that's what
you're talking about.
And so yeah, if you're in a
collectivistic society, then
absolutely, feeling a sense
of pride in the collective
can serve the same
functions as feeling
an individual sense of pride.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you went to Burkina Faso
to do a lot of research
and gather a lot of
evidence and came up
with the how pride is
universal and even has
an evolutionary aspect to it.
What would be the
next step in terms
of things you want to research?
JESSICA TRACY: Wow, OK.
Well, so the Burkina
Faso stuff, that was fun.
And I think it did actually
lead to a lot of other research
directions, some of
which are in the book.
So for example, in
Burkina Faso, we
found that people
recognized pride.
But we wanted to know
do people show pride
the same way in all cultures.
So we did a study
of the Olympics,
in which we looked
at Olympic athletes
from countries all
over the world.
And this is a great opportunity
to look at pride displays
because the Olympics is an
occasion where people feel
a ton of pride if they do well.
And you have people from
all different countries
because it's the Olympics.
And we found that the
same pride display
is shown by people from
countries all over the world.
We found no cultural differences
in displays of pride.
So even people from
collectivistic or Eastern
cultures were just as likely
to show pride as people
from Western cultures.
There was no gender
differences either.
And then we did a study where
we thought, OK, well, all
these people, this is great.
But these are all
professional athletes.
Unlike our Burkina
Faso participants,
they have plenty of
exposure to other cultures.
Maybe they're showing
pride because that's
our human nature.
But maybe they're showing
it because they've
learned when you win an
Olympic medal and you're on TV,
this is what you're
supposed to do.
So we were able to
do another study
of a sample of
individuals who actually
couldn't have learned to show
pride from watching others.
And that's because they were
blind athletes, participating
in the Paralympics Games.
And so we looked at
these blind athletes,
including a subsample of
congenitally blind people,
so people who in their lives had
never seen anyone show pride.
And when we did that, we
found the exact same thing,
that even these congenitally
blind athletes who've
never seen anyone
display pride, when
they win a match-- and
this was all judo athletes.
When they win a judo match,
they do that same thing--
expansive posture,
head tilt up, arms
extended out from the body.
So that was kind of
nice evidence, I think.
And so when I say
pride is universal,
it's partly because of
the Burkina Faso evidence.
But it's also things
like this, where
we're seeing these displays
in such a universal way.
SPEAKER: OK, if there
are no more questions,
let's proceed to our
book signing next.
But first, please
give a warm thank you
to our author, Jessica Tracy.
[APPLAUSE]